[Music]
[Applause]
stupid [ __ ] noah every year oh i made
it didn't i
this week is sacred
we're going to fire ireland and this is
why straight people hate us
and also
heteronormativity judeo-christian
pathology
analyzes
for whatever reason call it magic time
sort of works differently here
[Applause]
and that is our makeshift little family
we all met 10 years ago working at the
same cursed brunch spot bottomless
mimosas [ __ ]
jackie chan hey you got a refill here
bud
i can't believe you talked me into this
again i come here i just feel terminally
alone
oh are you all right it's fine it
happens all the time do you want some
whiskey it would help with your knees
you trust me i'm a doctor
do they have a house on the beach but we
can't go over there we are literal traps
nice excuse me i think you may have the
wrong house
have you seen the way they're drinking
they're clearly using us for free liquor
well promise me you'll try to have a
good time do not let these people think
that they are better than us because at
the end
never mind
okay guys like that are ruining this
island
play harsh time
i have never met somebody who has made
it so clear that they think they're so
superior than everybody else i don't
think i'm better than you
[Music]
you think that if you're vulnerable for
just one second that it's all gonna come
crashing down oh my god my baby's
drowning i don't think i want to be
implicated in this dj
[Applause]
oh you guys you're like all i have we're
family that means something to me what
are we gonna like hug and wrap this up
how does this end why don't we just get
a little cup and dance
the defense is wrong my biological clock
is second like this penelope cruz oh
[Music]
[Music]